in this video I'll be defining four
binary operators for sets I've defined
two sets a and B to help give some
examples so the first is a union B which
equals a set containing elements P such
that P is an element of a or P is an
element of B the next is the
intersection a intersection B equals the
set containing elements P such that P is
an element of a and P is an element of B
the next is the set difference of a and
B which equals the set containing P or
elements P such that P is an element of
a and P is not an element of B and
finally we have the symmetric difference
which is going to be very helpful when
you actually complete the symmetric
difference algorithm challenge so the
symmetric difference of a and B equals
the set difference of a and B Union with
the set difference of B an A and finally
I will define the irrational numbers
which I hinted to at the end of last
video so the irrational numbers are
simply the real number real numbers
minus the rational numbers and that
equals the irrational numbers